We're asked, what time is it?
So first, we want to look at the
hour hand, which is the shorter
hand, and see where
it is pointing.
So this right over
here would have
been 12 o'clock, 1 o'clock, 2
o'clock, 3 o'clock, 4 o'clock.
And it looks like it's a
little bit past 4 o'clock.
So we are in the fourth hour.
So the hour is 4.
And then we have to
think about the minutes.
The minutes are the longer hand,
and every one of these lines
represent 5 minutes.
We start here.
This is 0 minutes past the hour,
then 5 minutes past the hour,
then 10 minutes past the hour.
So the time is-- the minutes are
10, 10 minutes past the hour,
and the hour is 4, or it's 4:10.
Let's do a few more.
What time is it?
So first, we want to
look at the hour hand.
That's the shorter
hand right over here.
It's at-- let's see.
This is 12, 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
And it's between 9 and 10.
It's just past 9.
So it's still in the ninth hour.
It hasn't gotten to
the 10th hour yet.
The ninth hour's from starting
with 9 all the way until it's
right almost before
it gets to 10,
and then it gets
to the 10th hour.
So the hour is 9, and
then we want the minutes.
Well, we can just
count from 0 starting
at the top of the clock.
So 0, 5, 10, 15, 20, 25, 30.
It's 9:30.
And that also might
make sense to you,
because we know there are
60 minutes in an hour.
And this is exactly
halfway around the clock.
And so half of 60 is 30.
Let's do one more.
What time is it?
So let's count.
This is 12, 1-- actually,
we can even count backwards.
We can go 12, 11, 10.
So right now we're
in the 10th hour.
The hour hand has passed 10,
but it hasn't gotten to 11 yet.
So we are in the 10th hour.
And how many minutes
past the hour are we?
So this would be 0, 5, 10,
15, 20 minutes past the hour.
That's where the longer
hand is pointing.
It is 10:20.